T
THIS WHOLE TIME WE WORK WITH I
UFL ON DOING STAYING IN THE
VILLAGES VERY EARLY ON THEY'VE
ALSO WE'VE ALSO WORKED TOGETHER
ON DOING SOME TESTING AND UNDER
SERVED AIRPORTS WHICH HAS BEEN
NOT VERY VERY IMPORTANT. I'M
GOES TO SOME OF THE NUMBERS AND
WHERE WE ARE SOME THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE DOING I TO CONTINUE
IN THE IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
COVID NINETEEN CORONAVIRUS
FROM- VERY BEGINNING YEAH WE'VE
STRESSED OUT FEW MAIN POINTS
ONE IS PROTESTS OWNER AND TALK
ABOUT SOME THINGS DOING A TO
CONTINUE THAT EFFORT BUT THAT'S
IMPORTANT YEAH. YES VERY CLEAR.
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING WHICH IS
STILL VERY IMPORTANT- SUPPORT
FOR HOSPITAL HEALTH CARE
WORKERS THEN OBVIOUSLY- YOU
KNOW INTERACTION OF THE OF THE
VIRUS INTO FLORIDA SO IF YOU
LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE IN KIND OF
WHERE WE'VE BEEN PARTICULARLY
YOU KNOW OVER THE LAST MONTH
WHEN WE- S. CLEAR TESTING OUR
WEAPONS WERE WERE LOW AT THE
TIME CDC SAID ON SOME TWO SIX
FIVE AN OLDER HAS SENT THAT
EVIDENCE NINE OUT OTHER
INTERNATIONAL BUT- SO YOU. WHAT
KIND OF THE SHARP OF APRIL WE
WERE TESTING AT PROBABLY
SIMILAR LEVELS PER CAPITA THAT
OTHER STATES- WERE EXCEPT FOR
THE NORTHEAST BUT- BUT MUCH
DIFFERENT IN WHAT WE ARE NOW
BUT THE POSITIVITY RATE- WAS
BASICALLY ABOUT TEN PERCENT-
FOR THOSE FIRST STOP. FOUR TO
SIX WEEKS AND SPOKE YOU DID TEN
THOUSAND PASS YOU GET A
THOUSAND POSITIVE IS KIND OF
WHAT WE WERE LOOKING OUT THERE.
THEN I. APRIL POSITIVE
MOVEMENT. TIVITY RATE I BEGIN
OF MAY. OUR THAT SECOND JUNE. I
WAS REALLY THE BEST START
TESTING- THAT WE HAD HAD GOTTEN
ON IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA IN
TERMS OF LITTLE POSITIVITY WE
WORK STAND. THEN TAP. INTO. BUT
THE PEOPLE THE- PEOPLE PASS THE
POD. WITH VERY LOW SO YOU LOOK
AT THE BEGINNING OF MAY YOU
KNOW WE WERE UNDER FIVE FOR ALL
THE WAY THROUGH I JUNE
THIRTEENTH WERE FOUR POINT NINE
PERCENT. NOW THE JUNE YEAH I
JUNE THIRTEENTH WEEK SIX SIX TO
THIRTEEN. YOU STARTED TO SEE
EVEN THOUGH FOUR POINT NINE IS
STILL GOOD. WE WERE THREE FOR
THREE FOR THE WEEK BEFORE. TO
SEE A LITTLE CREASE IN THE
POSITIVE. THAT WAS DRIVEN BY
DISCRETE. WE WERE SAYING IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
BUT I THINK I WAS KIND OF THE
BEGINNING OF THEN THE NEXT WEEK
WE GET INTO IT. AGAIN YOUR NOT.
GOING. TO THOUSAND. TWO POINT
5% DAVID E. R. SO YOU'RE
TESTING A LOT OF PEOPLE BUT THE
FOR. THAT'S THE POSITIVE IT'S
HOW IN IN THE FILE WEEK. HUGE
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
ATTACKS THAT ARE ON BUT ALSO AN
INCREASE IN THE POSITIVITY FROM
NINE POINT FIVE. TO ELEVEN
POINT 9% AND A PAST WEEK WE GET
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
TABS- BUT IT JUST ON. PERCENT
POSITIVITY IN THE WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE TIVITY IT'S BEEN ABOUT
1415% UP PRETTY CONSISTENTLY
NOW FOR MORE THAN A WEEK I MEAN
REALLY PROBABLY ABOUT EIGHT TO
TEN DAYS- SO YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING. HE IS AND I'LL
TALK. EVERY K. THAT'S DOCUMENT
THERE MANY MORE INFECTIONS THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY OCCURRED WE ONLY
DIAGNOSE A SMALL FRACTION OF
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF INFECTIONS
SO IF YOU. ARE AT 5% POSITIVITY
TEST THE THOUSAND- AND THEN YOU
TEST THE HUNDRED THOUSAND THE
POSITIVITY STAYS THE SAME YEAH
YOU'LL HAVE TWICE AS MUCH PASS.
BACK POSITIVE- BUT IT'S NOT
REALLY EVIDENCE THAT IT'S MORE
PREVALENT- WHEN YOU ARE. SEEING
THE POSITIVITY INCREASE MORE
PEOPLE AT WHATEVER AMOUNT DOING
TESTING POSITIVE YOU KNOW
THAT'S AN INDICATION OF THE
POSITIVITY INCREASING AND SO.
SOME OF THESE ARE THINGS WE SEE
BUT A LOT EIGHTY. TWO OH THIS
RECORD CASE BASICALLY BEEN THE
SAME I MEAN YEAH WHEN WE DO
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND TABS
WORKING MORE DOING FOR THAT.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE. BUT THE. FOR
SENATE. PRETTY CONCERNED NOW IS
TO GET BACK DOWN TO AT THREE
THAT 3% WE WERE IN MAY IN EARLY
AT THIS TIME YEAH THE 50%
THAT'S FAR CRY FROM YOU WERE
SAYING- IN PLACES LIKE THE
NORTHEAST A 304050% EARLY IN IN
THE- BACK. NO WE ARE NOW TO.
WHERE WE'VE TESTED 10% OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION SO TWO POINT
TWO MILLION PEOPLE- WE GOT
ABOUT OBVIOUSLY ALL CLOSED
LITTLE UNDER TWENTY TWO
MILLION. FLORIDIANS AND SAID
THAT'S A THAT'S A LOT OF TASKS-
BUT I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WAS SIGNIFICANT WE WANTED TO
EXPAND TESTING AND WE'VE DONE
IT. AND THEN HERE'S THE STATS
THE LAST WEEK. THIRTY ALMOST
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
TESTED FOURTEEN POINT 8% TAX
THE POP UP SO AGAIN IF YOU TAKE
THE MATE PERCENTAGE WE WERE
PROBABLY AT FOUR FIVE PERCENT.
SO THAT'S GOING TO GENERATE A
LOT MORE PASSED UP. THAT YOUR
TEST. AT FOURTEEN POINT 8% IN
THE POSITIVE IT IS NOT UNIFORM
THROUGHOUT THE CITY OF FLORIDA.
YOU GOT MINE GATE THEY BEEN
TWENTY PER CENT. YOU LOOK AT
HILLSBOROUGH THEY BEEN BETWEEN.
AND PERCENT I THINK ORANGE
COUNTY HAS BEEN OVER FIFTEEN
PERCENT- AND THEN THERE'S OTHER
PLACES THAT I HAVE BEEN LAX AND
THAT. YOU KNOW MAY NOT PLACES
WERE ONE OR 2% IN MAY YOU KNOW
NOW. PICTURES. PRIESTS IN THE
POP. BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF FOR
THAT ARE STILL IN THE SINGLE
DIGITS SO I MEAN ONE KEEP IT
THAT WAY. AND THEN BE ABLE TO
DO THEN THE MEDIA AGE IS REAL
SICK. ON TOP OF THEM ABOUT THAT
IN A MINUTE THE MEDIA AGE OF
EVERYBODY TESTING RIGHT NOW
POSITIVE FOR THIS PAST WEEK. IS
THIRTY SIX AND AS WE SEE IN THE
CASES INCREASE- THE MEDIAN AGE
EVERY SINGLE DAY HAS BEEN IN
THE THIRTIES SOMETIMES AS LOW
AS THIRTY THREE. NOW WHY IS
THAT IMPORTANT WELL BECAUSE
THIS IS A VIRUS THAT DOES NOT
AFFECT ALL AGE GROUPS EQUALLY
IT'S MUCH MORE LETHAL FOR
PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THEIR
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES. IDENTITY
IS IN YOUR TWENTIES AND
THIRTIES I'LL GO THROUGH SOME
OF THE NUMBERS BUT BASICALLY
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE UNDER FORTY.
YOU DON'T HAVE SIGNIFICANT
COMORBIDITIES YOUR THE
PATHOLOGY RATE FOR THAT IS
PRETTY CLOSE TO ZERO- SO WHO.
IS TESTING POSITIVE- IT'S JUST
AS IMPORTANT AS HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE TESTING POSITIVE THIS IS A
PROBABLY A TWO DECADES. FROM WE
WERE WITH THE MEDIAN AGE I'M AT
THE END OF MARCH BEGINNING OF A.
WE HAD BEEN. THIS UPSWING. THEN
BY A LOT OF IN THERE TO AND I
TESTING PA. AND HERE'S A
EXAMPLE OF KIND OF THE RISK
PROFILE BY AGE GROUP WHICH IS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT SO YOU LOOK
AND KIND OF THOSE THE YOUNGER
KIND OF THE FIFTEEN TO FORTY
FOUR THAT IS THE BULK OF THESE
POSITIVE TESTS ARE NOW COMING
FROM AND PARTICULARLY THAT
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY FOUR YEAR
OLD H. I MEAN FAR IN A WAY IT'S
BLOWING EVERYBODY AT. COVID
RELATED ALLERGIES AND IN THOSE
AGE GROUPS I MEAN THE RATE IS
INCREDIBLY INCREDIBLY LOW- MANY
OF THE PEOPLE IN THEIR-
TWENTIES AND THIRTIES OR
TESTING POSITIVE. R. E.
SYMPTOMATIC- THEY'RE BEING
TESTED BECAUSE MAYBE THEY WERE
EXPOSED MAYBE FOR WORKPLACE-
AND THEN THOSE WHO DEVELOP
SYMPTOMS MOSTLY DEVELOPED. A
MILD SYMPTOMS AND SO- THESE ARE
THE FOLKS WHO ARE JUST SIMPLY
LESS AT RISK. THAN THE FOLKS
WHO YOU KNOW ARE SIXTY FIVE
PLUS AND THERE'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE TO AND THE REST
PROFILE. EIGHTY FIVE IN LAS.
SEVENTY EIGHTY FIVE IS
DEFINITELY LOWER AND THEN SEE
THE SEVENTY FIVE IS DEFINITELY
LOWER THAN THAT AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY YOU GO DOWN FURTHER-
ABSENT- MORBIDITY IT GOES DOWN
VERY VERY LOW. THE CASE BOTH.
BELLY BEING DRIVEN. PRIMARILY
THE REST A GROUPS NOW IT'S
TIME. JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE
TWENTY ONE AND- I'M IN THE THEY
NOT THIS. IF YOU GET SYMPTOMS
AT THAT MEAN THAT CAN'T OTHER
PEOPLE AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THEY WERE
OBVIOUSLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
IS RAY EIGHT. OF WHERE WERE
SENT. CASES GOING IN THE LAST
MONTH YOU KNOW IT'S ONLY BEEN
SEVEN BY. AT THE AGE. THERE ACT
IF YOU. COMORBIDITIES PRESENT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT PRACTICALLY-
AT 0% I PATAUDI RATE OBVIOUSLY
AS THEY GET OLDER IT GOES DOWN
YOU KNOW THAT'S OBVIOUSLY A
GOOD THING YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WANT TO SEE. HE SAYS IN THE IN
THE UPPER AGE GROUPS- BUT
REALLY IT SHOWS YOU KIND OF.
THAT REAL SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN THOSE TWENTIES AND THIRTY
YEAR OLDS- ARE TESTING POSITIVE
THAT'S WHERE MOST OF THE
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION. IS
REALLY COMING PARTICULARLY. IN
METRO AREAS LIKE YOU KNOW LIKE
THE ORLANDO IN HILLSBORO YOU
LOOK AT THEIR MEET NATE THAT'S
DROPPED MEDICALLY AND- METRO
AREAS THAT'S FUELED. BY BY SOME
OF THOSE FOLKS IN THOSE AGE
GROUPS THAT WERE. SO IT'S- SO
WHEN YOU SEE THE CASES
OBVIOUSLY IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE SEEING. I BUT IT ALSO
DOES MATTER WHO I THINK. THAT
THE TERMS OF MORE TECH BE MORE
ET AND IF LUCK AND IT. PEOPLE
DON'T USUALLY ABOUT THE K.
FATALITY BY ASKING OF. IS MUCH
LOWER- THAN MANY OF THE OTHER
MAJOR STATES- SO CASE PATAUDI
JUST THE NUMBER OF FATALITIES
RELATED TO COVID DIVIDED BY THE
NUMBER OF- KOBE CASES- AND SO
WE'RE NOW I THINK- YOU KNOW
UNDER TWO PERCENT- AND THAT'S
BEEN TRENDING DOWNWARD AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S A REFLECTION
OF THE FACT THAT. A LOT OF THE
NEWER CASES LAST MONTH HAVE
BEEN DRIVEN BY PEOPLE WHO ARE
AT A VERY LOW RISK- FOR WITHOUT
SO- PART OF IT TOO AND I THINK
THE DOCTOR TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THE THINGS YEAH THEY ALSO HAVE
MORE TO LOSE AT THEIR DISPOSAL.
TO BE THREE PEOPLE THANK. YEAH
THAT. IDEA OF. THE CURVE WAS
NOT WOULD NOT HAVE MY
INFECTIONS ARE. NO ONE SAID
THAT YOU CAN DO SOMEHOW. IT
YEAH WHY'D YOU KIND OF SPREAD
IT OUT SO THAT THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM IS IN A POSITION TO BE
ABLE TO HANDLE- WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS IN CLEARLY YOU KNOW. WE
DID THAT IN FLORIDA MARCH IN
APRIL THE PROBLEM HAD. A
RELATIVELY LOW HOW LITTLE
OCCUPANCY WE HAD A LOT OF
AVAILABILITY. AND THEN EVEN IF
THEY PUT THE ELECTIVE SURGERIES
BACK IN- MOST PARTS OF FLORIDA
YOU STILL HAVE ABOUT A 25%
AVAILABILITY. AND SO THAT'S
PART OF IT BUT IT'S ALSO THE
TREATMENTS AND THE OTHER THINGS
LEARNING FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
OTHER STATES. AND SO THEY GOT A
REALLY GOOD JOB ABOUT THAT BUT
YEAH WE HAVE. PROBABLY THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION BUT THEN
THEY HAVE CASE FOR CALIBRATE
THAT THAT'S NOW BELOW TO IN OF
COURSE. ANYMORE INFECTIONS IN
CASES. THE ACTUAL INFECTION
SAUDI RATE IS GONNA BE MUCH
MUCH MORE- THAN THAT. OVERLOOK
TOTAL TO IN FLORIDA THREE DAY
ROLL AVERAGE YEAH THAT LITTLE
PEEK IN MAY AS I'VE SAID THIS
BEFORE BUT THAT'S ARTIFICIAL-
THAT WAS. ABOUT SIX WEEKS WORTH
OF BACKLOG NEGATIVES THEY GOT
DUMPED OVER TWO DAY PERIOD- SO
REALLY IT HAS BEEN A PRETTY
SMOOTH THE SENT- FROM WHERE WE
WERE AT MARCH IN TO WHERE WE
ARE NOW THE BEGINNING OF JULY.
AND WE'RE AVERAGING I THINK.
THE PASSED OUT WEEK I THINK
IT'S LIKE SIXTY TO SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND TEST RESULTS A DAY.
ARE COMING IN PART OF THAT IS
BECAUSE WE'LL TALK ABOUT WHAT
SORT OF DOWN TO EXPAND TESTING
PART OF IT THE HOSPITALS YOU
THEIR TESTING EVERYONE COMING
IN. FOR D. AT THEIR FOR CHOPPER
THEY GET A CAR ACCIDENT. OF SO
YEAH MORE TESTING AT THE CLOSE.
YOU DID MARCH APRIL. ONE OF THE
THINGS WE LOOK. AT OUR SEN
DRAMATIC IN THE- AND- AGAIN YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES THEIR SIGNAL IN
THERE SOMETIMES THERE'S NOISE
IN THIS CLEARLY. YEAH YOU CAN
SEE IF YOU WOULD GO BACK IN MAY
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
INCREDIBLY STABLE AND LOW.
THROUGHOUT MOST OF MATTER- LATE
APRIL ALL OF MAY BEGINNING OF
JUNE. AND THEN AS YOU SEE YOU
START TO SEE IN THE SECOND WEEK
IN JUNE A LITTLE BIT OF AN
INCREASE. IN THE COVID OUT LIKE
ILLNESS SO THIS IS- PEOPLE THAT
GO TO THE E. D. FOR COVID OR
INFLUENZA LIKE ILLNESSES THAT
WE TRACK SO THOSE THOSE EITHER.
ET VISITS THEN YOU LOOK AS WE
HEAD INTO THAT- MIDDLE OF JUNE
YOU SEE THE INCREASE IN THE
COVID- OUT LIKE ON THIS VISIT.
AND THEN IT GOES UP EVEN MORE
TOWARDS THE END OF JUNE AND
THEN RELAY AT THE VERY DID YOU.
USE I SEE IT SENATE EIGHT BACK
TO SEE TO KNOW WHETHER THAT A
THAT A SUSTAINED TREND. I DHABI
SO THOSE ARE SENIOR MASS IN THE-
YEAH THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT WE
WHEN YOU GET POSITIVE. TEST
RESULTS. ONE THESE LAST. EIGHT
A WEEK TO TURN THE AROUND IN SO
YOU BE GETTING A- TESTS TODAY.
AND MAY HAVE TAKE THAT THAT
PASS. US SEVEN DAYS AGO THEY
MAY HAVE BEEN INFECTED SEVEN
DAYS BEFORE THAT THE CHANCES
ARE. THEY PROBABLY ALREADY IF
THEY NEED TO PROBABLY ALREADY
VISITED. BY THE TIME SOME OF
THESE TEST RESULTS COME BACK
IN- IN SO IT'S UNFORTUNATELY
YOU'RE NOT IN A SITUATION WHERE
THESE INSTANT INSTANTANEOUS.
TEST RESULTS BUT THOSE ARE
THINGS TO LOOK AT THESE COVID
IN INFLUENZA LIKE ILLNESS
INDICATORS. WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THAT AND I
SAID BEFORE IS GET STRESSED THE
CASES. ARE SIMPLY DETECTED
INFECTIONS THERE ARE HAPPEN WAY
MORE INFECTIONS THAN DOCUMENTED
CASE IS. AND SO IF YOU SEE FIVE
THOUSAND CASES TEN THOUSAND
JUST UNDER. THAT IS NOT THE SUM
TOTAL OF THE- THAT BEEN ACTIVE
WE WERE IN A- THOUSAND. I A OF
MARCH APRIL. FIRST WHAT INJURY
MEDICAL. CASE FIRST WE IN OF
HAPPENING AND RIGHT HERE'S AN
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT THIS IS
REASON THE END OF JUNE CDC OUT
THE DID IN A BODY IN SERRA FOR
SURVEYS AND DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE- I THINK IT ONE HERE IN
SOUTHERN AND THE FOR TOWN MORE
PALM BEACH BROWARD AND MIAMI
DADE AND IF YOU'RE LUCKY THEY
WERE TESTING FOR THE PRESENCE
OF ANTIBODIES IBM I. G. G. AND
THIS WAS DONE OVER A PERIOD
APRIL SIXTH APRIL TENTH. AT
TIME THERE'D BEEN TEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED CASES REPORTED.
BASED ON THE ANTIBODIES IN THE
SERA PREVALENCE CDC- BELIEVES
THAT THERE ARE ACTUALLY A
LEVANTINES MORE INFECTIONS. AT
THE TIME IN SOUTHERN FLORIDA
THAT'S A 1-001-700-0400
INFECTIONS THAT IT ACTUALLY
OCCURRED AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THE ANTIBODIES THE IDG TAKES
ABOUT TWO WEEKS TO DEVELOP I GM
PROBABLY ABOUT SEVEN DAYS. I
SAID YOU'RE TESTING KIND OF AT
THE BEGINNING OF APRIL YEAH
THESE ARE IN ACTION THAT MAY
HAVE HAPPENED IN FEBRUARY BUT
CERTAINLY THE FIRST COUPLE
WEEKS OF MARCH PROBABLY NOT
THAT MUCH LATER- BY IN LARGE
AND SO. THAT ZERO PREVALENCE
CLEARLY WOULD HAVE INCREASED BY
THE TIME YOU GET INTO A BRAWL
AND THEN SO IF YOU WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THE ZERO PREVALENCE WAS ON
YOU KNOW APRIL TENTH. YOU KNOW
YOU REALLY NEED TO FIGURE OUT
OF WHEN THOSE INFECTIONS
OCCURRED WHEN THE ANTIBODIES
DEVELOPED AND SO I WOULD
IMAGINE IN UNIVERSITY OF MIAMI
HAS DONE THIS FOR MIAMI DADE
THEY'VE HAD- INFECTION RATE X.
TIMES HIGHER. THAN THE NUMBER
OF CASES WE DO. TESTING THIS
ARE DRY BESIDE. HEALTHCARE AND
FOR FIRST RESPONDERS AND WHAT
WE'RE FINDING PLACES LIKE MIAMI
SEVEN TEN CENT PASSED OTHER
BODIES SOME IS LIKE ORLANDO
JACKSONVILLE. THERE MOVEMENT
THE THREE THREE AND A HALF
PERCENT STEP PAUL THAT IS WHEN
YOU ARE AT THAT FRONT LINES IS
NOT CAPTURED IS THAT THE- CASE.
IS NOW. TO MEET THAT I RISK.
CREDIT THE CASE IT WOULD SAY
ALSO THAT THE FOR. ARE THAN A
SIMPLE ROCKET. GREAT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO INCLUDE THE END.
DOING A SURPRISE INSTEAD WHY C.
NOW AS THE INFECTION. RATE FOR
CORONA IF YOU ARE POINT TWO SIX
I THINK THEIR BEST ESTIMATE YOU
KNOW IN FLORIDA IF WE DO HAVE A
ONE POINT 9% CASE FATALITY RATE
IF YOU ARE GOING TO SAY
SOMETHING LIKE TEN ELEVEN
PERCENT. HIGHER YEAH THAT BUT
OBVIOUSLY BUMP THAT DOWN TO OUT
TO ABOUT POINT ONE NINE SO BUT
I BRING THIS UP JUST BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW HOW
THIS HAS DEVELOPED. IN THESE
WERE FACTIONS THAT LIKELY
OCCURRED BEFORE THEY WORKED ANY
FIFTEEN DATA STOP THE SPREAD.
BEFORE WE YOU KNOW WHO THOUGHT
THAT THERE WAS NECESSARILY I'D
SPREAD SO I IT SHOWS THAT THIS
THING HAS BEEN SIR. FOR IN OUR
KIND. AND WE INITIAL THOUGHT
KIND OF AT THE- OF MARCH AMID
THING AMAR. FOR TWO. AS YOU
KNOW YOU SEE CASES- JUST PEOPLE
JUST TO PUT IT INTO CONTEXT
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON- YOU
THERE'S NO NEED TO REALLY BE BE
FEARFUL ABOUT IT I MEAN WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THAT. THE DIFFERENT
STEPS THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN TAKE
YOU KNOW THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE
STATEWIDE- BY TO AT THE END OF
THE DAY YOU KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN AROUND-
FOR QUITE SOME TIME. I THINK
THIS IS IMPORTANT I NEED. OF
THE PHYSICIANS HERE I'LL TALK
ABOUT IT BUT- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I THINK DID NOT GET AS
MUCH. ATTENTION AT THE TIME AND
ONLY NOW I THINK PEOPLE ARE
STARTING TO REALIZE IS WHEN BE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC NATIONAL
EMERGENCY WAS DECLARED IN THE
MIDDLE OF MARCH. CDC WORKS AT
B. E. D. VISITS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY FOR THINGS LIKE HEART
STROKE AND OTHER SERIOUS.
ILLNESSES AND WHAT YOU SAW WAS
A MAJOR MAJOR DECLINE IN THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE VISITING B. E.
D. ARE FOR THINGS LIKE LIKE
HEART PROBLEMS. NOW NO ONE
BELIEVES THAT THOSE PROBLEMS
ALL OF A SUDDEN JUST STOP. WHAT
HAPPENED WELL AS PEOPLE WERE
PROBABLY FEARFUL ABOUT GOING
INTO THE HOSPITAL BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT. MAYBE THEY WOULD CATCH
THE VIRUS THERE MAYBE THEY
THOUGHT THAT THE HOSPITALS HAVE
CAPACITY TO DEAL WITH THEM ACT
WHO KNOWS MAYBE THOUGHT THAT.
WAS TAUGHT STAY FARM A THAT
MEANS TO GIVE. I BUT THERE I'LL
BE A LOT REASON FOR. THAT DEATH.
BEEN NCDC HOURS REPORT. I
BASICALLY A TRIBUTE SAYS IT MAY
IT THE OF ACCESS MORE TO. NADA
SURF WITH. OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS TWO PEOPLE
PUTTING OFF VISITING HOUSE. FOR
REALLY WHITE THREATENING. SO
WERE HAPPENS IS YOU MAY NOT DIE
THEN BUT THE- WERE AND THEN BY
THE YOU DO PRESENT IN THE HOUSE
EUROPEAN DOT YOU'RE SICK. WHICH
OTHERWISE WOULD BE A YOUR MARCH
HE WRAPPED AS IT INCREASE
DRAMATICALLY SO. WE'LL SEE BE
BE VERY DAY UNDERSTAND BAHASA
ARE SAY PLACE TO BE. THIS IS
SOME THAT YOU DO NOT TO PUT ON
OTHERS. THEY HAVE GREAT SAFETY
PROTOCOLS YOU'RE LESS LIKELY TO
GET CORONAVIRUS HERE THEN A LOT
OF PRIVATE RESIDENCES OR WHAT
OTHER THINGS YOU COULD BE DOING
SO PLEASE COME IN AND DON'T LET
PROBLEMS FESTER THAT DOES
IMPACT. ABSOLUTELY WILL IMPACT
MORTALITY- IF YOU DON'T COME
AND GET THE CARE THAT YOU NEED
WHEN YOU NEED IT. SO OUR NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY THROUGHOUT THIS
WHOLE THING IS TO PROTECT THE
VULNERABLE BECAUSE OF THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT THE
VIRUS HAS. ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
SIXTY FIVE AN UP AND PEOPLE
THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT
COMORBIDITIES- WE'VE ADVICE
REALLY SINCE MARCH AND EVEN AS
WE GOT INTO THE DIFFERENT
PHASES. THE GUIDANCE HAS NEVER
CHANGED ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
SIXTY FIVE AND UP- WERE
RECOMMENDING. VISINE FLOYD
CROWDS AND TO MINIMIZE CLOSE
CONTACT WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
NOT IN YOUR HOUSEHOLD THAT IS
THE SAFEST WAY. TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE NOT UP PUTTING
YOURSELF IN A SITUATION WHERE
YOU COULD CONTRACT THE VIRUS
AND- I THINK BY AND LARGE IN
THE BID BEING HERE IN THE-
JUSTICE. BICKER YOU KNOW THEY
REALLY. I THINK HE DID THIS
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING I
REMEMBER TALKING TO GERRY
LESTER IN EARLY MARCH. I WAS
LIKE YOU KNOW YOU THEY ARE
PLANNED THEY'VE DONE A LOT
STUFF AND DOWN. REALLY MISS HIM
AND I KNOW. THAT ONE THE
PHYSICIAN GET TALK ABOUT IF
SOMEBODY. AISLE AREA IN THE-
WHERE THE POPULAR YOUNGER. TO
SEE MORE K. AND EVEN. PDP IN.
TEN TO HERE ELLAGIC AND A LOT
OF THAT IS BECAUSE I A. REALLY
MAKING EFFORT TO PROTECT. SO
THE MASS FOR. OUR POPULATION.
IS TO. CROWD AND MINIMIZE
CONTACT OUTSIDE HOME. THIS OUT.
SEARCH I AND IT'S MORE WHY WITH.
WHO WERE IN THERE TO. AND
THIRTIES SO ANYONE IN MY GEN.
HOUSING YEAH THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU DEFINITELY BE A
CONCERN. THEN OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
SOMEBODY. YEAH THAT IS EITHER
KIDS OR GRAND KIDS IN THAT AGE
GROUP YEAH THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THAT YOU SHOULD BE
COGNISANT OF AS WELL. ALSO
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS SO IF
YOU'RE LUCKY THE YOUNGER YOU
ARE YOU KNOW THE PATAUDI RATE
IS INCREDIBLY LOW CLOSE TO ZERO
FIVE. THERE REGARDLESS OF AGE
IF YOU DO HAVE SOME OF THESE
ARE SIGNIFICANT COMORBIDITIES-
YOU'RE DEFINITELY AT AN
INCREASED RISK OF FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS AND SOME OF THE
THINGS I THINK PEOPLE WOULD
UNDERSTAND AND USE
INSTINCTIVELY. ANYTHING WITH
HEAVY DUTY BELONGS LIKE A
CYSTIC FIBROSIS OBVIOUSLY IF
YOU HAVE A SERIOUS HEART
CONDITION BUT WHAT THEY SEE A
LOT- IN THE HOSPITAL WITH THE
PATIENTS WHO. MAY NOT IN THEIR
SEVENTIES OR EIGHTIES MAYBE IN
THEIR FIFTIES. THAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MAYBE HAVING
IN A SYMPTOMATIC ILLNESS OR
MINIMAL SYMPTOMS OR ILLNESS
THAT REQUIRES HOSPITALIZATION
OUR SOMPO MORBIDITY I DIABETES.
OBESITY THAT'S OF THE OTHER
VERY VERY COMMON COMORBIDITIES
THAT HOSPITALS THROUGHOUT
FLORIDA I THINK YOU'RE SEEING
OVER AND OVER AGAIN SO AND-
FOLKS NO CITY BEIJING THE SAME.
AS R. SIXTY FIVE AND UP YOU'LL
BE SURE TO CROWDS IN IN. CLOSE
CONTACT. SIDE THE HOME YOU'RE
SOME WHO'S IN. A GORE BECAUSE
YOUR REST IS ELEVATED I DO CO
COMORBIDITIES. BUT COURSE OUR
LONG TERM CARE FOR IS K. OF
WHAT FOR THE MOST AT RISK
POPULATION IS HOW WE GET OUT
EARLY ON IN. I KNOW SOME OF THE
ARE THE DOCTOR LAZARD WILL TALK
TO THE- BY. YOU KNOW WE ARE
PROTECTED THESE LONG CARE FOR.
YEAH WE'VE BEEN HAVING PAGE BE
RE ADMITTED THAT THEY WERE
COVID BECAUSE FEARED THAT WOULD
HELP ME SPREAD THE OPERATE
AGAINST THEM VULNERABLE AND I
THAT THAT WAS THE WAS THE RIGHT
POLICY. I BUT WE ALSO UNDER. IS
OKAY YOU HAVE SOMEBODY COVID PA
IS A REP THE LAW CARE IN THE
HOT BUT THEY'RE MEDICALLY. WE
DON'T WANT TO THE NERVE THEY
CAN'T BE ISOLATED BECAUSE I'M
SO YOU'RE PUTTING THE OTHER REP.
REST ARE BUT IF THEY DON'T MEET
BEYONCE WOULD BE GOOD IF THEY
COULD BE ISOLATED APPROACH SO
WHAT STARTED DOING A ALL WHAT A
STABBING COVID. NEEDED NURSING
BUT HE SO NOW TWELVE COVID
DEREK NURSE FOR. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF. BETTER ABLE YOU HAVE
PAGE. WHO ARE COVID. BUT THEY
DO. THEIR THEIR HEALTH RISK ARE
POSSIBLE. AND A- THOUGH WITHOUT
MARTEL RATE IS MUCH HIGHER FOR.
WHO ARE SET DR WE ARE FINDING A
LOT OF NURSE HOME RESIDENTS
LONG TERM CARE RESIDENTS TO DO
AS FAR. CONVALESCING IN
ISOLATING AND THAT'S REALLY
THIS IS REALLY WORTH IT
BECAUSE- IF YOU PUT SOMEONE
BACK INTO A LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY. THAT IS STILL
CONTAGIOUS AND THEY CANNOT BE
ISOLATED. THAT IS GOING TO END
UP SPREADING IN THOSE
FACILITIES YOU'RE GONNA END UP
SEEING MORE PATIENTS COME TO
THE HOSPITAL SO I WANT TO THANK
SECRETARY MAKING FOR WORKING
HARD- OVER THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS. I DO THIS I THINK THIS
IS GOING TO BE REALLY
SIGNIFICANT YEAH WE DIDN'T HAVE
THIS. IN MARCH AND IN APRIL WE
FIRST ONE WAS BROUGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF APRIL I KNOW. THIS
REFLECTS YEAH WHEN I DO GET A
BETTER SITUATIONS BETTER FOR
LONG TERM CARE FACILITY. BETTER
FOR HOSPICE- IN IN REALLY
BETTER BETTER FOR THE RESIDENTS
AND ALL THE SAME. REASONS THE
OTHER THING WE'RE DOING AND I'M
EIGHT. THREE PROBABLY WOULD. WE
WENT PAST IT. ARREST AND TESTED
THAT. WHICH WAS IN. BUT WHAT
WE'RE ALSO AND FORWARDED ALL
STAFF AT LONG TERM FOR NEED TO
BE. ONCE EVERY TWO WEEKS AND SO
HAVE A IN WE'RE PROVIDING
DIFFERENT- TYPES OF TEST FOR
THAT NOW I WILL REMIND PEOPLE
YOU KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
POSITIVE TEST WITH THE STAFF-
WHEN WE GET IT THE FIRST TIME
WE HAD ABOUT A 3% POSITIVITY
RATE NOW THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS- MORE PREVALENT IN THE
COMMUNITY. THAT IS LIKELY TO BE
REFLECTED I REFLECTED THE STAFF
MEMBERS AND SO I'M HOPING THAT
IT'S LOWER THAN THE 15% AND IT
MAY BE BECAUSE THEY HAVE TESTED
LOOK FOR THE GENERAL POPULATION
THE WHOLE TIME- BUT WERE ASKED
TO SEE THAT NOW WHAT WE WILL DO
IS OBVIOUSLY THEY- DIDN'T. AND
THEY ENTER WITH PRESS AND ITS
IMPORTANCE CORY MECHANISM TO
KEEP DOING SO YOU GOT ALMOST
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO
WORK PLEASE FORGIVE US FOR AND
FIFTH PLEASE IN A FLORIDA OVER
TWO HUNDRED. ALMOST. TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOLKS STATE.
I'M TWO WE THAT'S GONNA BE A
LOT OF TESTS. AND GONNA BE A
INTO BE SOME NEW CASE IS A
WITHOUT QUESTION BUT IF YOU I.
THAT THEN WERE FOR TWO I THE
BOTTOM IN THE WAY. HOW DO WE
REALLY NEED TO AND OF COURSE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE ALMOST 85% OF
THE CORONA RELATED FATALITIES
HAVE OCCURRED IN AGE GROUP
SIXTY FIVE AND PLUS. I THINK
NATIONALLY IF YOU IF YOU GET AN
HONEST ACCOUNTING. ANY LONG
TERM CARE RESIDENTS WHETHER
THEY DIE IN THE FACILITY OR AT
THE HOSPITAL. I'M IF YOU COUNT
THAT WHICH FLORIDA AS YOU HAVE
A MAJORITY OF THE OPEN RELATED
PATAUDI. WOULD BE RATHER IT'S
OF LONG TERM CARE FOR. I KNOW.
AND IT THAT'S A LOT OF ARE
COUNTRY AND- YEAH IF YOU TO
WEAR THE- OF MORE. BE A- FROM.
THE ONE OF OUR BEST YEAH YOU
GOT YOU KNOW BE. UNDER NOT
PERFECT HOUSE BOTH KNEES SO.
ABOUT OUR AND THEY REPRESENT
OVER. OF THE FIFTH AUDI'S THE
STATE AND SO WERE TO CONTINUE
BUT A LOT BENEFIT. ON
PROTECTING THE MOST OF ALL.
FIRE SOCIAL THE- WE ARE
OBVIOUSLY LOT OF WE STRESS THE
I'M HAPPY YEAH I KNOW IT'S
THINGS KINDA CHANGED LITTLE BIT
AT THE END OF BEGIN OF JUNE
YEAH THERE ARE A LOT YOU SAW A
LOT MORE LARGE GATHERED YOU SAW
DIFFERENT THINGS- AND I DON'T
KNOW IF MAYBE PEOPLE THOUGHT
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING YOU KNOW
IT'S KIND OF TODAY'S NEWS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE DOING-
AND SO REALLY POINTING OUT THE
BEST WAY YOU CAN PROTECT
YOURSELF A PARTICULAR PROTECTOR
ONE OF ONE EIGHT SLOW THE
SPREAD. IS TO AVOID BLOW BASES
HOW DID PLACE IS A CLOSED.
SETTINGS AND SOMETIMES CAN BE
ALL THREE AND IF YOU'RE AT A AT
A PRIVATE PARTY INSIDE- IN AIR
CONDITIONED HOUSE AND YOU GUYS
ARE. PEOPLE ARE SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER AND YOU'RE TALKING
OVER MUSIC OR SOMETHING YEAH
THAT IS GOING TO BE- INCREDIBLE
FACTOR FOR TRANSMISSION. WHEN
YOU'RE IN CLOSE IN CLOSE SPACES
PARTICULARLY WITH AIR
CONDITIONING HOW YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE MORE. OF TRANSMISSION
THEN YOU WOULD IF YOU WERE AND
NOT EVEN FOR INSIDE IF IT'S A
LITTLE MORE SPACIOUS. AND
CERTAINLY OBVIOUSLY IF YOU'RE
OUTSIDE- BUT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IF YOU DO IT BUT- YOU KNOW. NOT
GONNA BACK AT. ME MEDIAPRO. AND
WE BOUGHT SAID NOW MAY DAY THAT
IF YOU CAN'T SOCIAL DISTANCING
YOU KNOW WEARING A FACIAL
COVERING CAN CUT DOWN ON THE
TRANSMISSION- WE BELIEVE SOME-
BUT IT'S NOT IN LIEU OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING YOU CAN SOCIAL
DISTANCING YOU STILL WANT TO DO
THAT BECAUSE- THE BEST WAY TO
PREVENT. INFECTIONS WHETHER YOU
INFECTING SOMEBODY ELSE OR
SOMEBODY ELSE INFECTING YOU SO
THIS CLOSE SPACES CROWDED
PLACES IN CLOSE CONTACTS
SETTINGS- REALLY ARE. WHAT
MAKES THAT THIS THING HAS
SPREAD. AND THERE ARE WE NOW
KNOW I THINK. PRETTY CLEARLY
YEAH OUTDOORS FRESH AIR
SUNLIGHT HEAT HUMIDITY IT'S
LESS RISK IT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S
NO RISK I MEAN IF YOU'RE VERY
CLOSE AND DOING THINGS LIKE.
YEAH DEFINITELY BUT IF YOU'RE
JUST OUTSIDE. YOUR THE CHANCE
OF YOU ACQUIRING THIS OFF FROM
FLEETING CONTACT FROM SOMEBODY
YOU KNOW IS VERY VERY LOW YOU
KNOW THE HIGHER RISK ARE THOSE
INCLUDES CROWDED SPACES WITH
THE POOR VENTILATION. FLOOR I
THINK YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE
SAYING ALL THIS HAPPENED
THROUGHOUT THE SUN BELT FROM
THE CAROLINAS TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- PLACES LIKE ARIZONA
TEXAS FLORIDA THAT ARE HOT IN
THE SUMMER. YOUR PEOPLE TEND TO
WANT TO RETREAT INSIDE THE AIR
CONDITIONING THAT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE BUT IF YOU HAVE
GROUPS OF PEOPLE IN THE AIR
CONDITION. ARE BAD IS BETTER
FOR THE- AND IF YOU ROUTE IN
THE SUNSHINE AND THAT'S I THINK
BEEN BEEN PROVEN OVER BREAKING
AND IT'S- DIFFERENT AND- MINS.
DIFFERENT AND SO WE TALK ABOUT
BACK IN MARCH THE MINIATURIST
FLATTEN THE CURVE I MEAN PEOPLE
DON'T REALLY TALK ABOUT THAT AS
MUCH ANYMORE BUT- THE THEORY
BEHIND IT WAS YOU KNOW IF YOU
HAD INFECTION JUST SPIKE- YOU
GET PATIENTS PUTTING THE
HOSPITAL THE SYSTEM MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO HANDLE IT- SO WE WANTED
TO SLOW THE SPREAD OUT WE
COULDN'T EXPRESS NOT JUST A YOU
KNOW I'VE SAID WE'RE GONNA HAVE
CASES YOU KNOW FORWARD. IT'S
ALLOWED US TO POSITION I'VE
EVER BEEN HANDLE YOU KNOW WHAT
IS GOING ON YOUR BACK AT THE
END OF MARCH WE HAD SEVEN STATE
SUPPORTED TESTING AIDS FIVE
APRIL FIRST WE A TOP PEOPLE
SITES WHICH TIME WAS IT THAT
POINT. THERE DO YOU WHICH I
THAT WAS ALL WE DID THE DAY
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE SEVEN TESTING
SITES AND THE SITES LOAN IT
DOWN ALMOST SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND PASS AND SELL THE
SITES WE HAVE WE HAVE DRIVE
THREE SITES WE HAVE WALK UP
SITES WE HAVE POP UP RETAIL
SITES WE HAVE A MOBILE R. V.
WILL GO AROUND PARTS OF FLORIDA
AND TEST PEOPLE SO USE IN MORE
AND MORE I THINK BAILABLE
ACROSS THE STATE OF FLORIDA
OBVIOUSLY WHAT THE STATE IS
DOING. YOU KNOW THIS PART OF
THAT I'M THE HOSPITALS ARE
ANOTHER THE LOCALS ARE DOING
STOP PRIVATE SECTOR- BUT WE'RE
NOW IN A SITUATION WHERE-
THERE'S A LOT OF THESE TEST
SITES IN A WAY THAT WASN'T
BASES IN MARCH NOT ONLY HERE
BUT ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY. IN
MY IN MAY AND WHEN OUR NUMBERS
HELLO I WAS BEGGING PEOPLE GET
FAST. SOME OF THESE PLACES ROLL
WE LIKE TRY. I NOW IN THE- OF
WEEKS OF THAT TRACK IS
INCREASED SO THE CAPACITY IS
INCREASED SOME OF THE LIKE THE
ORANGE COUNTY CONVENTION CENTER
THAT WOULD DO ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED AS THE DAY. YOU KNOW
NOW THEY'RE DOING SEVENTEENTH.
A DAY AND THEY EXPANDED LANES
AND THAT SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS SOME OF THESE RETAIL
SITES WE DO TWENTY FIVE A DAY
NOW SOME OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
A DAY. I SAY TO YOU DEFINITELY.
MORGAN IN IN GETTING TESTED
WHICH IS. ONE WE ARE TO. DO THE
IS AVAILABLE ON A WIDER BASIS.
THE BODY TESTING AND THE REASON
IS YOU GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE NOW
WHO ARE TESTING. ENDING WITH.
MAY BECAUSE OF WORK MAYBE
BECAUSE SOMEONE THEY KNOW I GOT
INFECTED. AND YET THE PROBLEM
IS IF YOU'RE NEGATIVE. IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU CAN'T GET
IT THE NEXT DAY I MEAN IT'S SO
IT REALLY A FLEETING THING TO
HAVE A NEGATIVE TEST- IF YOU DO
AN ANTIBODY TEST. YET THE
ANTIBODIES. SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY SIGNIFICANT IN TERMS OF
THE INFORMATION AND SO FOR
SOMEBODY IF YOU'RE NOT
SYMPTOMATIC. THERE'S IN A BODY
CAST REALLY BE GOOD THEY CAN'T
DETECT. A RECENT INFECTION IF
YOU HAVE IDEA MANABADI IT MEANS
THAT YOU'VE- LIKELY BEEN
INFECTED WITH A RELATIVELY
RECENT TIME. I GGN ABOUT DAYS
WOULD BE YOU KNOW AT LEAST TWO
WEEKS PRIOR MAYBE LONGER THAN
THAT. UP BUT RIGHT NOW WE'VE
BEEN DOING IT FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND FOR FIRST. BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR FOLKS
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT WOULD BE WORKING ON. WAYS
THAT WE CAN GET MORE ANTIBODY
TESTING OUT THE GOOD THING
ABOUT THE ANTIBODY TEST. YET
THE RESULTANT THE MINUTES- THAT
PART IS IT'S A BLOOD TEST IS
NOT A SWAB SO SOME PEOPLE WOULD
RATHER BE SWAP THEN HAVE. WHAT
THEY CAN BUT- IN FROM HIM TO
HAVE THE WORRY. ANOTHER MAJOR
ISSUE THAT WE WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT IN MARCH AND APRIL. WAS
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
PARTICULARLY FOR FIRST FIRST.
FIRST AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
OUR DEPARTMENT OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AT SEN OUT. HUGE
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES THE
HOSPITALS BUT PARTICULARLY TO
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES. WE
IMPOSED THAT PPP MANDATE ON
THEM IN MARCH. AND THEN WE SENT
THE N. NINETY FIVE MASKS AND
FACE SHIELDS WE SENT DOWN. WE
SENT THIS STUFF FOR THEM
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE ALSO HELP.
HOSPITALS OUT WITH THINGS THAT
THEY NEEDED. NOW MOST I HAVE
NOT TALKED TO ANY HOSPITALS.
WHO ARE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH PP
AT THIS POINT WHICH IS A GREAT
THING- IT'S ABOUT. WE'RE IN A
MUCH BETTER POSITION WE WERE.
PROPERTY WHILE. HIRED EIGHT OF.
YOU SEE ARE THE RESIGNING THE
FATALE RATE IS LOWER IT'S- YOU
HAVE BETTER TREATMENTS TODAY
THAN YOU DID AND IN MARCH- WE
BROUGHT A LOT OF HYDROXY CLERK
QUEEN. TO FLORIDA TO HAVE THAT
AS AN OPTION A LOT OF POSITIONS
YOU'VE USED IT THE WHOLE TIME
LIKE IF. THERE IS IN THAT STUDY
THAT CAME OUT OF THE LAND SAID
THAT HAD WITHDRAWN IT SAID IT
WAS BAD. NOW HENRY FORD MEDICAL
IN DETROIT SAYS THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY BEEN VERY HELPFUL. MY
MIND IS WE WANT TO PROVIDE THAT
FOR POSITIONS TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS WITH THEIR PATIENTS.
THE CONVALESCENT PLASMA HAS HAD
SUCCESS RANDAZZA BEER WHICH WE
WORK WITH HHS TO GET THE
HOSPITALS I MISS HAD SUCCESS-
AND THEN YOU'VE GOT THINGS LIKE
THAT THE STEROID IN THESE OTHER
THERAPIES. SO THE PATIENT
EXPERIENCE IS BETTER TODAY THAN
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN IN MARCH I
OR- IF THEY DRAW. AN OBVIOUS
DIFFERENCE SINCE I'VE LEARNED A
LOT ABOUT THE BY WHICH IS A IS
A REALLY REALLY GOOD THANKS SO
FLATTENING THE- YOUR PUSHING
INFECTIONS OUT LONGER NEED YOU
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE LONGER.
BUT I THINK IN TERMS OF
OUTCOMES YOU MIGHT RATHER IN A
SITUATION NOW AND HAVE TO HAVE
DONE THIS BUT EVERY LEVEL IN
MARCH AND APRIL. THE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES SET. SUPPORT FOR ME
PHILLIPS THERE'S A COUPLE. THAT
I SOME OF THE AISLE THE FOLKS
AT THE- FOR. I WHAT IS I IT WAS
WITH THE VICE. ON THEY- WANT TO
BE. AND WAY THEY CAN. ONE OF
THE THING. THAT WE SEE A NEED
FOR A SOME PERSONNEL SUPPORT.
OFFER SOME OF OUR HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS AND THE REASON IS. YOUR
DATE WE HAVE. FIFTEEN THOUSAND
PLUS BEDS AVAILABLE THE CENSUS
25% AVAILABLE OBVIOUSLY
HOSPITAL YOU'D WANT TO RUN
PROBABLY AT 90% CAPACITY.
NORMALLY SET SO THE BETTER
THERE- THE ISSUE IS. HOW THE
PERSON NOW CAN BE USED SO FOR
EXAMPLE IN MIAMI DADE. YES
LARGEST HOSPITAL SYSTEM JACK
AND- IT ALMOST FORTY PER. OF
THE PEOPLE COME IN FOR. CO
THINGS LIKE CAR ACCIDENTS
CHILDBIRTH ARE TESTING POSITIVE
ANOTHER A SYMPTOMATIC THEY
DON'T NEED TO BE HOSPITALIZED
FOR COVID. UP FIVE. ONE
SOMEBODY TESTS POSITIVE THERE'S
A WHOLE SET OF PROCEDURES THAT
THEN GET PUT IN PLACE THAT
REQUIRES MANPOWER SO THAT THOSE
FOLKS ARE ISOLATED AND THEIR-
THE COVID DOESN'T SPREAD TO
OTHER PEOPLE. AND SO WHAT
THEY'RE FINDING IS OKAY YOU GET
SOMEONE GETS IN A CAR ACCIDENT
THE GET SWABBED THEIR POSITIVE.
THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
HOSPITALIZED FOR COVID BUT THEY
DO NEED CARE FOR OTHER THINGS
THAT STILL REQUIRES KIND OF THE
COVID PROCEDURES TO BE PUT IN
PLACE. SO HAVING- A LITTLE BIT
OF RELIEF ON THAT ELEMENT AND
THERE'S DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
THEY CAN DO WOULD BE GOOD SO WE
PUT IN THAT REQUIRE. I'M GONNA
BE FACE GRANITE AND WE HOPE
HAVE SOME. OUT THERE THEY'RE
FINE NOW BUT JUST LOOKING AT-
PARTICULARLY AT THE CAESAR CAN.
WHERE THERE'S A HIGHER
POSITIVITY. WELL THAT'S GOING
TO BE REFLECTED IN THE GENERAL
PATIENT POPULATION WHO INTO.
OUR FOR FROM FROM COVID NINETY
SO THEY'RE KIND OF AT THE
HIGHER END WITH THE 40% BUT
EVEN SOME OF THE ONES IN
CENTRAL. BUT I LIKE THE KNOW
HOW IT SAID THERE ONE ST I THE-
BEING OTHER TECH. SWAP YOUR-
YEAH YOUR I NINETY NINE PER.
RATE THE MATTER MOST BUT IT
PLACE AND THAT IS THAT JUST
CHOIRS ALLOW CARE AND A LOT OF
MY TO ME OUR NEEDS AND OUR- OF
WORK. HARD THIS. SURE THAT THAT
CONTINUES FLOWING THAT HHS HAD
BEEN SENDING IT DIRECTLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. AND IN
FLORIDA WAS THAT DISTURBING AT
ALL THE HOSPITALS BASED UPON
NEEDS WORK VERY WELL- BUT NOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS THEY'RE
GOING FROM THE MANUFACTURER
DIRECTLY TO THE HOSPITALS WHICH
IS FINE. BUT WE JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S NO GAP THERE
SO WE'RE WORKING WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE ON THAT. AND THEN FINALLY
JUST SOME OF THAT THE CHEMICALS
FOR THE LABS. THEY'RE DOING A
LOT OF TESTING IN THESE
HOSPITALS AND SO THEY'RE
RUNNING OUT OF SOME OF THE
STAFF I KNOW THIS STUFF
AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE K. AND
SO. WE HOPE TO BE ABLE TO GET
IT YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAD. LOWER
NUMBERS WE WOULD GET A THING
BECAUSE THEY WERE SENDING IT
PLAYS THAT WERE HIGHER. SO THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE THESE CASES
RUNNING A LOT OF TASKS. WILL BE
THAT DONE LITTLE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO TURN AROUND THESE TESTS
VERY QUICKLY SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
WORKING ON- REALLY
SIGNIFICANTLY SO- WE'RE BETTER
PREPARED NOW AND I THINK THAT.
THE STEPS TO PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE IS CLEARLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING. WE CAN DO TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT THAT OF
CORONAVIRUS. POP IN AND- BEEN
VERY HARD NOT JUST STATE LEVEL
ALL ARE LOCALE PLEASE AND- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WORK IN.
ASIDE WITH LAST. HAVE YOUR.
THIS ISSUE. AT HELLO. AGAIN AND
THEN WE CAN UP THE- FOR SIMPLE.
I NELSON. YOU WANT TO JUST ONE
THANK YOU FOR HAVING A YOU ONE.
KICK IT OFF AND THAT MAKES IT.
THANK YOU GOVERNOR- BETTER
THANK YOU GOVERNOR MY NAME'S
DAVE NELSON ON THE PRESIDENT
VIEW OF HEALTH WHICH MEANS I
OVERSEE. THE GAINESVILLE
JACKSONVILLE- CAMPUS AS WELL AS
TWO BEAUTIFUL HOSPITALS HERE IN
THE VILLAGES- I'D LIKE TO GET
MAYBE A LITTLE REFLECTION AT
THE SYSTEM LEVEL FOR WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH IN TERMS OF THE-
COVER NINETEEN AND THEN I'LL
LET MY COLLEAGUES GIVE YOU MORE
SPECIFICS. SO OTHER THAN
OVERSEAS HEALTH SYSTEMS WERE
ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR BRINGING
BACK THE UNIVERSITY OF FLORIDA
AND THE PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS
THE DIFFERENT UNIVERSITIES- FOR
US HEALTH. AND SO JUST TO GIVE
AN IDEA WE CURRENTLY HAVE DONE
WELL OVER FORTY THOUSAND TESTS-
AND SO WE HAVE BEEN TESTING A
LOT THROUGHOUT THIS CURRENT-
PANDEMIC WE USE A TECHNIQUE
CALLED PULLING. WHICH IS WE
DON'T DO A SINGLE TEST TEN
PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE WE TAKE.
AND YOUR APPLES BUT A SINGLE
TEST. AND IF IT'S NEGATIVE ALL
TEN OR NEGATIVE IF ANYONE'S
POSITED TO GO BACK AND HAVE TO
TEST EACH ONE. THE IT'S IT
RESOURCE ALLOWS YOU TO SAVE
PRECIOUS THREE. THAT THE
GOVERNOR TALKED ABOUT AND IT
ALLOWS US TO TURN WITHOUT
PROTESTS THEY- IN THOUSAND TO
THE- AT IS JUST AN EXAMPLE. SO
YEAH PROBABLY TEST I THINK MANY
PEOPLE OUT BUT WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN THE SHE US HEALTH
SO AND SAFETY. FOR STUDENTS TO
BACK TO IN THE LAST WEEK OR
WEEKS SEEN A WE- EVERY HAS BEEN
SO. ABOUT WE HAVE IN THE
INCREASE NOT A SOME BATIC PLOY.
TO WORK- THE LIKELIHOOD OF
HAVING A SYMPTOMATIC INFECTION
IS MUCH LOWER THAN MUCH OF THE
REST OF THE STATE SO WE'VE BEEN
VERY FORTUNATE. HOWEVER IN OUR
THREE HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS WE
HAVE. LAST WEEK SAW A SPIKE IN
DIAGNOSES CASES AS THE
GOVERNOR- REFERRED TO THEM AND
WE HAD A LITTLE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED POSITIVES. IF YOU LOOK
AT THE MEDIAN AGE AND WHERE
THEY DISTRIBUTE. GAINESVILLE
JACKSONVILLE CENTRAL FLORIDA
HEALTH WERE KIND OF ONE TWO AND
THREE BUT INTERESTING MEDIAN
AGE OF AROUND TWENTY FIVE WAS
OCCURRING OUTSIDE OF THE
HOSPITALS WHICH ARE ALL AROUND
FIFTY EIGHT SO. WE'RE STAYING.
WILL COME INTO THE MARCH ZERO
WE'RE COMING TO THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM TO GET TESTED. AND WE'RE
SEEING I THINK THE H. PUSHED
BACK IN TERMS OF WHO'S GETTING
HOSPITALIZED PROBABLY IN THAT-
MID TO LATE FIFTIES WHICH IS A
CHANGE I THINK FROM OUR EARLY.
EXPERIENCE THAT WAS DOMINATED
UNFORTUNATELY GOT A NURSING
HOME PATIENTS AND THOSE WITH
VERY HEAVY COMORBIDITIES- AND
SO. OVERALL IF YOU LOOK AT
HEALTH CARE CAPACITY SO WE TEST
A LOT WE'RE SEEING A FAIR
AMOUNT OF DISEASES IN THE YOUNG
SO OUR THREE BIG HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM STACKED UP TO. TAKE A
SECOND OR THIRD PEAK- RIGHT
NOW. ALL THREE OF OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS HAVE VERY
GOOD CAPACITY- I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF MISCONCEPTION IN THE
GENERAL PUBLIC WHEN YOU HEAR
THAT LET'S JUST SAY OUR
GAINESVILLE CAMPUS IS 90% FULL.
THAT'S A GOOD THING BECAUSE
WE'RE USUALLY CLOSER TO A 100%
FULL BECAUSE WE NEED TO RUN
FULLY TO CIRCUITS THAT THE
SERVER. ARE YOU HAVE TO TREAT
THAT WE CONCERNED. ONE FOUR.
THE STICKAM WITH ELECTIVE
SURGERY SIX. AND KNOW WE CAN
CONTINUE TO EVALUATE BUT AT
LEAST SO FAR AND- SUCH FLORIDA
HEALTH HOSPITALS. AND OUR
GAINESVILLE JACKSONVILLE
COMMUNITY WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CAPACITY- AND DON'T SEE THAT
BEING A PROBLEM BUT- WE
PROBABLY COULD GO TEN FOLD
HIGHER THAN WE SAW IT AND WHAT
YOU WOULD SEE IS THE FIRST
WAVE. BUT WE NEVER GOT INTO THE
MITIGATION STRATEGIES BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T SEE WHAT SOUTH
FLORIDA HIT. THERE'S NO DOUBT
MIAMI WILL HAVE A LITTLE LESS
CAPACITY. THAN THE US HEALTH
SYSTEM- BECAUSE WE HAD NEVER
GOT THE POSITIVE RATES OF
15220% SO ANYWAY OVERALL. I
THINK WE'RE DEFINITELY SEEING A
COMMON YOUNGER PERSONS SPREAD.
HOSPITALS ARE GETTING MORE
ACTIVE AND- WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WATCH THOSE NUMBERS BUT HAD
MANY TRIGGERS TO PULL TO OPEN
UP A SYSTEM MORE IF WE NEED
SAID. RIGHT DR SPRY ONE TO TALK
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
THE E. D. AND SOME OF THE STUFF
THAT YOU'VE YOU'VE BEEN SAYING
THROUGHOUT AS MANY MONTHS. THE
SONG CORRECT I'M GERMANS' PRIOR
I'D LIKE TO- PERSONAL FIXED NOW
GOVERNMENT CENTERS FOR COMING
HERE AND SPEAKING WITH US IT'S-
IMPORTANT HE GETS A LOT OF
INFORMATION FROM THE POSITIONS
THAT. THAT ARE IN THIS EVERY
DAY- AND IT SHOWS AND YOUR THE
CONTROL OF THE DATA WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT AND- I'M THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT HERE AT THE VILLAGES
AND ALSO THE VICE CHIEF OF
STAFF. FOR THE MEDICAL STAFF-
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE SLIDES THAT
HE PUT UP THERE WAS ONE TO
REFLECT WHAT THE CDC REPORTED
ABOUT. SEVERITY OF OTHER
ILLNESSES. AND WE'RE NOT JUST
SEEING AN INCREASE IN THE
SEVERITY BUT ALSO IN THE
MORTALITY ASSOCIATED WITH THE
TO SUPPORT ATTACKS STROKE.
OTHER INFECTIOUS ILLNESS
DISAPPEARED FROM. BETTER BUT
STILL. YOU KNOW TO THIS DAY
WE'RE SEEING PATIENTS THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN HERE EARLIER-
THAT HAS A DIRECT EFFECT ON.
THEIR OVERALL HEALTH- THERE'S
GOING TO BE. ISSUES WITH DELAYS
IN CANCER DIAGNOSES FOR NOT
JUST REACHING OUT AND COMING TO
THE ER BUT ALSO. TO EVEN IF THE
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN SO. YOU
KNOW MY JOB TODAY IS TO IS TO
LET THE PUBLIC KNOW AND
REASSURE THEM THAT. OUR
POLICIES THAT WE HAVE AND
PROCEDURES AND SCREENING
PATIENTS AND VISITORS. AND
STAFF ON A DAILY BASIS THAT THE
HOSPITALS ARE VERY VERY SICK.
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE HERE
AND READY AND THEN. IF YOU'VE
GOT ANYTHING THAT THAT YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT- YOU KNOW COME
IN DON'T DELAY. GREAT DOCTORS
ORDER CAN YOU TALK ABOUT SOME
IS THAT YOU'RE SAYING AND THEN
I'LL BE AND YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
MENTIONED SOME OF THE NURSING
HOME COME. IF YOU SPEAK ABOUT
THAT AS WELL ABSOLUTELY ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING US HERE AND FOR COMING
THAT TO BE WITH US HERE UFL-
ON. COVID PRESENTS SOME
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES-
THINGS AND NONE OF US HAVE SEEN
DURING OUR CAREERS. I ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES IS THE
WIDE RANGE OF OUTCOMES RELATED
TO AGE IT'S ANOTHER WORDS ONE
GROUP YOU SEE VERY LITTLE BAD
OUTCOMES IN ANOTHER VPC
DEVASTATING OUTCOMES. I REMAIN
OPTIMISTIC IT'S A BOUNDED
OPTIMISM SO IT'S GOT ITS LIMITS
BUT I'M STILL VERY OPTIMISTIC
AND WHY IS THAT. THE REASON
BEING IS THAT. THE GOVERNOR
SAID HIMSELF IS THAT PRIVACY
WILL MOST IMPORTANT
INTERVENTION THAT WE'VE DONE
HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON THE NURSING
HOMES AND I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
IDEA OF TESTING REPEATEDLY IN
GOING IN EVERY TWO WEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT THAT'S WHERE YOU
WATCH THAT POPULATION THE MOST
OF THE NOT ONLY THE WORKERS BUT
ALSO THE RESIDENTS IN LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES. THAT HAS BEEN
A HUGE A HUGE BREAKTHROUGH AND
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT STEP TO
TAKE. SENATE MOVES AND MAKES A
BIG CHANGE IN EFFECT BY THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT RISK
GROUP IN TERMS OF MORTALITY
THEM REALLY THE OUTCOME. THAT
MATTERS THE MOST. IT'S I SAID
ABOUT UP TO. ABOUT ADOPTING IS
THAT WHAT'S BEEN. WHAT'S BEEN
GOING ON HERE LATELY. IT'S BEEN
BEHAVIOR. AS THE FATHER OF A
TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD AND A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD I GET IT I
UNDERSTAND KIND OF WHAT SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES ARE. BUT MUCH OF
WHAT WE'VE SEEN LATELY IS.
BEHAVIOR DRIVEN. AND AGAIN YES
WE WANT TO SEE THAT STAY IN AGE
GROUPS BUT AGAIN THAT FEARS
THAT. UNMITIGATED BEHAVIORS
ANOTHER JUST KIND OF THINKING
OF NOW I'M NOT THINKING OF
TOMORROW THINKING OF OTHERS.
THAT SPILLS OVER INTO OTHER AGE
GROUPS. AND THEN WE'VE GOT
ANOTHER PROBLEM SO AGAIN I
THINK THAT WE HAVE THE TOOLS WE
HAVE A LOT OF STEPS SO WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD. BUT AGAIN WE NEED
EVERYBODY TO WORK WITH US ON
THIS TO FOLLOW THE RULES FOLLOW
THE GUIDELINES. TRY TO THINK
ABOUT OTHERS AS WELL ON SO MANY
PEOPLE ARE DOING AND THIS IS A
LONG HAUL THERE SOME CHALLENGES
HERE. BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
REASON TO BE OPTIMISTIC. AND I
THINK THAT THOSE STEPS WILL
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE AND
SPECIALLY WITH THOSE YOUNGER
AGE GROUPS THINKING ABOUT
OTHERS. TRYING TO PUT OFF SOME
OF THOSE THINGS THINK ABOUT THE
ONES YOU LOVE. THOSE GIVE ME
THE STEPS HERE REAL HELP ALL
THIS CONTINUE TO GET THIS UNDER
CONTROL. AND CONTINUE. TO HAVE
REASONS FOR OPTIMISM MOVING
FORWARD. RIGHT THANKS. OUR DR
LOAN KRANTI WANNA. WEIGH IN ON
SOME STUFF WE TALKED. FOR SO-
JEFF LONG COUNTRY MEDICAL. FOR
THE- HEALTH PROBABLY THE ONLY
REPRESENTATIVE IN OUTPATIENT
SYSTEM HERE. AND A LOT OF WHAT
WE HAVE AS A PATIENT CENTERED
PRIMARY CARE DRIVEN COMMUNITY
BASED HEALTHCARE MODEL. IS THE
ABILITY TO TALK TO FOLKS BEFORE
THEIR SET. AND PART OF WHAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO IS ENSURE
THEY HAVE THE CONFIDENCE TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK WITH US EITHER IN
PERSON. WITH FULL WELCOME THEM
INTO THAT CARE CENTERS. FOR IN
WHATEVER WAY THEY WANT TO REACH
OUT TO US. THE REAL KEY IS THAT
WE AS THE HEALTHCARE. DELIVERY
SYSTEM. HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE SAFE WHEN THEY COME IN.
SO WE'RE MAKING SURE WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR MONTHS NOW WE
SCREEN PEOPLE ON THE WAY AND WE
KEEP OUR OWN FOLKS WORKING
THERE. ARE SAFE AND WE KEEP THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING IN
CONTACT WITH SAFE. BY DOING
THAT WE ARE SURE THAT THEY CAN
GET THE CARE THEY NEED TO. KNOW
THE REAL KEY IS THIS MOST
PEOPLE AS THEY GET OLDER DON'T
NEED A HOSPITAL STAY EVERY
YEAR. BUT THE ONLY TO PRIMARY
CARE VISIT EVERY YEAR. SO WE'VE
SEEN DEMAND FOR SERVICES COME
DOWN. FOR INPATIENT FOR IN
PERSON. BUT OUR ABILITY TO
STILL MAKE SURE WE DELIVER ON
THE HIGH QUALITY SERVICE THAT
WE CAN IS KEEN. AND WHAT WE
KNOW IS IF THEY NEED TO COME TO
THE HOSPITAL THEY'RE GOING TO
GET OUTSTANDING AND SAFE CARE
HERE AS WELL. SO WITH THAT
WE'VE BEEN UP PRETTY
COMFORTABLE SENDING OUR
PATIENTS HERE ONE NINETY TWO.
BUT WE DO START OUT BY MAKING
SURE THEY NEED TO COME. THANK
YOU. AND I MEAN JUST FOR THE
COURSE OF THIS- PANDEMIC LIKE
PARTICULARLY THE RESIDENTS OF
THE VILLAGES. IT SEEMS LIKE
THEY'VE REALLY- YOU KNOW TAKEN
SOME OF THE GUIDELINES THE HARD
AND THEN YOU KNOW THEY'RE STILL
THEY STILL DO THINGS OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY ACTIVE
BUNCH BUT THEY'VE- THEY'VE DONE
IT IN A WAY THAT THAT'S
MINIMIZE RISK IS THAT BEEN YOUR
EXPERIENCE. IT HAS BEEN AND I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
REALLY DOESN'T GET THE CREDIT
THAT IT DESERVES SO THE
LEADERSHIP HERE AT THE
HOSPITAL. AND OUR LEADERSHIP IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH IN THE
COUNTIES HERE HAVE GOTTEN
TOGETHER TO FORMER GIVING A
CLEAR CONSISTENT MESSAGE. AS TO
WHAT'S BEEN EXPECTED AND THAT
CLARITY. AND THAT COMMUNICATION
PLAN HAS BEEN IN PLACE SINCE
MARCH. WE'VE HAD ONGOING ALMOST
INITIALLY DAILY. SOMETIMES TWO
OR THREE TIMES DAILY
CONVERSATIONS. NOW IT'S
PROBABLY JUST TWICE A WEEK. AND
I KNOW THAT THEY'VE- THERE WERE
CERTAIN THINGS SOME OF THE BIG
INDOOR GATHERINGS WHATEVER THEY
STOPPED IN MARCH AND THEY
CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND I THINK
THAT THEY HAD PLANNED ON MAYBE
DOING SOMETHING SOMETIME THIS
MONTH BUT I THINK THEY WERE
JUST WAITING ON THAT AND SO
THAT'S A- VERY MUCH YOU KNOW
FOCUSING ON ON THE FACTS AND IN
MAKING THOSE DECISIONS AND SO
YOU KNOW I THINK FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING. REMEMBER WHEN I WHEN
I CALLED THAT GARY AT THE
BEGINNING OF- OF MARCH AND- YOU
KNOW THEY THEY HAD A PLAN AND
THEY EXECUTED THAT'S REALLY
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO THAT'S PART
OF THE REASONS THAT YOU'VE HAD
A VERY LOW NUMBERS ON HERE.
EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVE A MORE
ELDERLY POPULATION- DOCTOR
NELSON ACROSS YOUR SYSTEM YOU
KNOW WE'VE HEARD THROUGHOUT
DIFFERENT PARTS OF FLORIDA
THAT- MARCH IN APRIL PATIENTS
OVER PRESENTING- REPRESENTING
YOU KNOW THEY TEND TO BE OLDER
VERY SAD. NOW MAYBE IF I'M NOT
YOUNGER MAYBE A NOTCH MILDER IS
THAT WHAT YOU GUYS ARE SAYING
IN TERMS YOU'RE COVID POSITIVE
PATIENTS YEAH I WOULD SAY
THAT'S ACCURATE ALSO WERE SO
MUCH SMARTER RIGHT YOU KNOW HOW
TO PUT BILL DOWN FROM POSITIONS
NO. PROBABLY NOT EVERYONE THEN
LATER WE HAVE RUN DISAPPEARANCE
TERRAE THAT HAVE A ROLE IN
HOSPITALIZATION SO I DON'T KNOW
I THINK PEOPLE WILL BE THEY'RE
DIFFERENT BY. OR IS GETTING EX.
BUT NOW WE'VE JUST GOT MUCH
MORE NOW THAT WE LEARNED THE
NEAR IN THE FROM THE REST WORLD
AGO TADAS. YOU KNOW THINGS THAT
WAS SET BY LIFE EVENTS WE'RE
ALL THE BETTER AND WE WILL.
FINE HOW MUCH OF THE DECLINE
DID YOU SEE AND HOW LONG DID
THAT THAT'S FINE AND WHERE ARE
YOU NOW YOU BACKED. NORMAL FOR
THINGS LIKE HEART AND STROKE
SYMPTOMS. YEAH WE HAD ABOUT A
4250% DECREASE IN OVERALL
DEVELOPMENT JUST WASN'T HERE IN
CENTRAL FLORIDA THAT'S ALL
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
EVEN MY FRIENDS THAT. AND WHERE
I TRAIN TO DETROIT. COVID
CAPITAL THEY THEIR VOLUMES WERE
DOWN AS WELL- NOW BLAMES IT
PICKED UP WE'RE STILL DOWN
ABOUT TEN PERCENT- BUT WE'RE
NOT. WORK WE WORK TYPICALLY YOU
KNOW EVEN IN THE SEASONAL AREA
RIGHT HERE. SO BECAUSE THERE
WAS A DECLINE AND- I THINK MOST
PEOPLE DON'T THINK THAT ALL OF
A SUDDEN PEOPLE STOP HAVING
HEART ATTACKS OR STROKES- THE
PEOPLE THAT. EVENTUALLY WOULD
COME PROBABLY SHOULD
ACCOMMODATE COMING IN WORSE
CONDITION. YES ABSOLUTELY AND
WE SAID THE SAME THING WHAT
HAPPENED TO APPENDICITIS WHAT
HAPPENED TO HEART ATTACKS SO
YOU KNOW WHERE DID THEY ALL GO
JUSTICE DOESN'T DISAPPEAR. SO
THAT THEY ARE THERE WAITING AND
WHEN THEY COME IN. THEY'RE
HAVING ISSUES WITH MORE
SIGNIFICANT CONGESTIVE HEART
FAILURE BECAUSE THEY THEY
ROLLED OUT THEIR HEART ATTACK
AT THE HOUSE. OR THAT. WENT ON
THE FLOOR THREE DAYS. NOW
WANTING TO COME AND GET HELP
WITH SINCE. FALL AT HOME THE
TWO. JUST MAKE IT THEMSELVES SO.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
DON'T IGNORE THESE THINGS JUST
BE. WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF. IN
YOUR IN YOUR- ABOUT. YOU KNOW
STATE OF THE HOUSE. EIGHT ALL
RIGHT WELL I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US HERE. FOR ALL
GOOD WORK DOING I SAID THAT THE-
FOR REALLY. GOING ABOUT AN A
REALLY REALLY SMART WAY AND
DAPPER. THEIR REST. AND OF
COURSE ONE TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT YOU KNOW AS WE SEE THIS
POSITIVE. ARISES WE SEE YOU
KNOW 15% AND COMMUNITIES MAYBE
NOT QUITE FIFTY PERCENT- BUT
ENOUGH A LOT OF PARTS YOU CAN
BE AT FLORIDA AS YOU START TO
SEE THAT. IT'S A- VERY. WE CAN
TAKE. PROTECTING THE BALL.
OBVIOUSLY BE GOT A BIG AFTER.
IN PLACE WITH THE LONG TERM
CARE FACILITY VERY IMPORT BUT
ALSO ARE SIXTY FIVE AN UP TOP
ELATION- THAT THAT THEY'RE
MINIMIZING OUT LARGE CROWDS IN
CONTACT ACT CLOSE CONTACT WITH
PEOPLE. OUTSIDE THEIR HOMES AND
FOLKS WHO ARE IN THAT AGE GROUP
ARE GONNA SELL WE HAVE CO
MORBIDITIES. YOU KNOW TO
UNDERSTAND A PARTICULAR IN THE
TWENTY AND THIRTIES. YOU'RE
SAYING THIS THING CIRCULATE-
MORE WIDELY- IN LOOK THIS WAS
PROBABLY CIRCULATING AMONGST
THAT AGE GROUP IN MARCH OR
APRIL. WE JUST WEREN'T TESTING
FOR IT- BUT I DO THINK IT'S
CIRCULATING AT A HIGHER RATE
NOW- CERTAINLY HAS IN THE LAST
FEW WEEKS. THAT IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN DETECTED EVEN IF WE WERE
TESTING A LITTLE BIT MORE
AGGRESSIVELY. SO THAT'S OUT
THERE. AND SO WHAT YOU WANT TO
DO IS JUST BE COGNIZANT OF
THAT- PARTICULARLY IN THOSE
TWENTIES AND THIRTIES- YOU DO
SEE MORE INFECTIONS THEIR- THAN
THAN ANYWHERE ELSE ANY OTHER
AGE COHORTS. AND SO GRANDMA
THEIR PARENT. I PLEASE KEEP
THAT IN MIND OVER THESE OUT OF
THESE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS- WITH
THAT WHAT HAPPENED ACT TAKE
SOME. QUESTIONS YES MA'AM. NO
NO I THE THEME PARKS HAVE BEEN
DOING GREAT I MEAN UNIVERSAL IF
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
AND THAT'S I THINK THE LESSON
IS YOU CAN DO FOR YOU WE HAVE
TO HAVE SOCIETY FUNCTION. YOU
CAN HAVE SOCIETY FUNCTION IN A
WAY. THAT KEEPS PEOPLE SAFE.
ARE IN WHEN YOU HAVE THE ALL
THE DIFFERENT- PROCEDURES THAT
THEY HAVE IN PLACE. PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE IT'S A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT DISNEY I HAVE NO
DOUBT IT'S GOING TO BE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT. I THINK THAT WHERE
ARE YOU START TO SEE THE SPREAD
IS JUST. SO SET. WHERE PEOPLE
LEFT THEIR DOWN USUALLY LIKE A
PRIVATE PARTY OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. YEAH THAT'S KIND OF WHAT
WE'VE SEEN SO BUT I THINK THAT
THE FOLKS. WHO PUT A PREMIUM ON
SAFETY THAT'S SHOWING YOU. THAT
YOU WERE ABLE TO HANDLE THAT.
HAVE SOCIETY FUNCTION THE ONE
PEOPLE GOING TO WORK- BUT DO IT
IN A WAY THAT YOU TAKE SOME
BASIC PRECAUTIONS AND SO.
REALLY IMPRESSED WITH WHAT
UNIVERSAL'S DONE AND I'VE I'VE
LOOKED AT. PLANNED I MEAN IT'S
VERY VERY THOROUGH. THEY'VE
BEEN DOING A GOOD JOB I MEAN
THAT'S YOU KNOW HERE'S THE
THING- YOU SEE WHERE THIS SITE
WHERE THE VIRUS IS SPREADING IN
THE IN THE AGE GROUPS IT'S
SPREADING AND- YEAH WE NEED TO
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE WE NEED
TO PROTECT THE FOLKS WHO RAN
THE AT RISK AGE GROUPS PEOPLE
WITH COMORBIDITIES- BUT- BUT
THE BROADER PART OF SOCIETY.
YOU KNOW DOING THE MODERATE
SOCIAL DISTANCING DOING THE
BASIC THINGS- WILL WILL GO A
LONG WAY. AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO DO WE NEED TO KEEP KEEP
PEOPLE WORK AND- I KEEP SOCIETY
FUNCTIONING. AND COMBAT IT THAT
WAY AND I AND I THINK WE WILL.
ONE A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE. MOVE
ON WHAT ELSE IS NEW THEY WERE
DOING THAT IN MARCH DO YOU
REMEMBER THAT. PROBABLY THE
PROBLEM. IF YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED
AMERICAN LANKFORD. BUT THE
TALKING ABOUT PARKING NOT SO
MUCH. SOME OF THE REQUIREMENTS
ARE- THEY WON'T ALLOW. ONE
BECAUSE IN FACT. SEVEN BASED.
ARE YOU. THANK OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
I MEAN WE WE'RE DOING SO MUCH
IN TERMS OF I'VE COMBATING THIS
FROM THE BEGINNING I MEAN IF
YOU LOOK JUST LOOK AT WHAT
WE'VE DONE WITH THESE COVID
ONLY NURSING HOMES I MEAN LIKE
THAT'S SAVING LIVES SO WE'RE
DOING ALL THAT WE CAN DO ON
THAT SO OBVIOUSLY YEAH I WENT
THROUGH THE NUMBERS I WANT US
TO BE IN MAY I WANT TO BE IN
EARLY JUNE OR READ 34% I MEAN
THERE WERE TIMES IN CENTRAL
FLORIDA I MEAN ORANGE COUNTY
SOMETIMES THEY HAVE DAYS EIGHTY
ONE AND A HALF 2% WOULD BE
POSITIVE THAT AND REALLY IF
YOU'RE ONE THAT. PERCENT THAT'S
BIG THE FALSE POSITIVE RATE
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN NOBODY
ACTUALLY WAS INFECTED ONE MAP
SO WE WANT TO GET BACK TO THAT
FOR SURE I THINK THAT I THINK
WERE I THINK WE STABILIZE AT
WHERE WE'RE AT AND YOU KNOW
OTHER STATES COULD DO WHAT THEY
WANT BUT YOU GO BACK AND LOOK
AT MARCH THE POSITIVITY RATES
IN SOME OF THOSE AREAS AND ONE
IN PERCENT I MEAN IT WAS 9060%
DEALING IN THERE SO IT'S A
LITTLE BIT PRINT AND ALSO IS
FOR PRESS THE VERSES IS MANY.
YEAH WE HAVE ONE. IN SOUTH.
THAT HAS NOT. FIRST TERMS
POSITIVITY. IN TERMS OF IN AND-
OF OUR EDIE VISITS A HOSPITAL.
AND THEN WE HAVE OTHER HERE IF
YOU LOOK AT LIKE. FLORIDA NO
DOUBT YOU'VE SEEN WAY MORE. AND
MY WARNS. BUT THE MEDIA AGE
SOMETIMES IN THE TWENTY ON A
DAILY. NEVER HELLO ABOUT I
THINK I THE MID. AND SO THE
CLINICAL. OF THAT. HAS BEEN HAS
ROLL. MODERN WARNS. AS ONE OF
THE LOW. CASE FATALE RATES THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE. YOU KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE SO THERE'S A LOT IT'S
NOT AN EVEN EPIDEMIC THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THERE'S A LOT OF
DIVERSITY HERE OBVIOUSLY I
THINK YOU KNOW THE SOLUTIONS
ARE GONNA BE TAYLOR DIFFERENTLY
BASED ON THE FACTS AT HAND-
BUT- I THINK THAT. WE YOU KNOW
WE'RE MUCH BETTER OFF TODAY. WE
WERE IN MARCH AND WE'RE MUCH
BETTER OFF TO WHETHER. COMPARED
WITH SOME OF THOSE OTHER AREAS
ARE SO YEAH THAT'S WHAT THEY
CAN DO WHAT THEY WANT BUT I
WOULD NOT I WOULD NOT DO THAT-
IF I READ THEM. WHEN I TOOK THE
ACTION AGAINST NORTHEAST. IT
WAS FACTUALLY THE CASE THAT
TENS OF THOUSANDS WERE COMING
TO MIAMI. RIGHT AT THE HEIGHT.
I DON'T NECESSARILY WANT TO GET
HELL I GOT A LOT OF PRIVATE
BLOW BACK BECAUSE I KNOW PEOPLE
TO TRAVEL BACK AND FORTH. THEY
TOLD ME THE LIKE LOOK WE'RE
FINE. AND I JUST DID IT BECAUSE
I THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS THE
SAFE THING TO DO AND I THINK IN
HIGH. YOU'LL. FLORIDA HAS IT
WORSE MAN. EARLY BECAUSE I. OF
THAT OF THAT THE SEATED. YOU
SEE THIS. IS A AND SO. AND
FLORIDA. AND SO A MILDER. IN MY-
IN A AND MAY. HERE NOW I THINK
THIS PART IS STILL. TO SEE YOU
KNOW MORE CASE. ARE WHAT SO THE
WORLD REALLY A MEAN IT'S A T.
EFFORT. IF WE'VE GOT ALL HANDS
ON DECK AND- I THINK THE PEOPLE
OF FLORIDA. ARE RESPONDING
POSITIVELY AND I THINK THEY'RE
RESPONDING IN WAYS. LIKE BUT
THERE'S NO NEED TO BE FEARFUL
LET'S JUST FOCUS ON THE FACTS
WE UNDERSTAND WE GOT TO DO WITH
THE STATE- AND LET'S LET'S
LET'S GET IT DONE- I THINK IF
WE DO THAT. YOU KNOW WE'RE
GONNA BE AND WILL BE IN GOOD
SHAPE AND I. THANK YOU TO
LISTEN TO SOME OF THE THINGS.
THAT YOU HEAR FROM SOME OF THE
FOLKS IN THE HOSPITAL SYSTEMS-
YOU KNOW. THEY UNDERSTAND YET.
THAT THEY PREPARE FOR THIS I
MEAN THIS IS WHAT THEY- WHAT
THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH. ASA
WORK CONSTANT CONTACT. SPOKE AS
I MENTIONED. THE PERSONNEL THAT
WERE GONNA BRING DOWN. ARDSLEY
BECAUSE- NOT COVID RELAY. L.
THAT PEOPLE ARE IN FOR OTHER
REASONS THEY TEST POSITIVE FOR
COVID. AND ALL THE PROCEDURES
THAT THEN GO IN. THAT THEN
TAKES AWAY SOME OF THE
MANPOWER. SO WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO HELP SUPPLEMENT THAT. THE
RENT THAT'S OF YOUR ALL THESE
THINGS WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
DO THAT. AND I THINK YOU WOULD
DO IT VERY WELL SO- SO. SO
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA BE OKAY.
REPORTER DO YOU RESPOND TO THE-
PRESIDENT RECORD NINETEEN ARE
PEOPLE WITH. NINETEEN WELL I IF
YOU LOOK SO YOU SEE I NOT SURE
WHAT HE MEANT YOU KNOW IN THE
CASE FATALE RATE IS UNDER PER
NOW WHICH IS MUCH LOWER THE A
LOT OF THESE STATES NOW OBVIOUS.
YOU KNOW IF YOU DON'T SO PEOPLE
HAVE NASTY ILLNESSES AND HOUSE
STAYS AND WE SHOULDN'T THAT I
MEAN I WE'RE FOLK NUMBER ONE ON
THE SAUDIS THE OLD THE OLD THAT
THE CARE HOMES IN THOSE AREAS-
SO YOU DO THAT BUT I DO THINK
IF YOU LOOK AT THE INFECTIONS
ON TOP OF JUST THE CASES WHICH
MAY BE TEN TIMES AS MANY YOU
KNOW THAT THOUGH THE RATE OF
LETHALITY IS MUCH LOWER IN IN
IN FACT THE TOP OF THE RATE.
CASE FINALITY RATE AND IT'S
SOMETHING EVEN THE CDC AT SEVEN
POINT 26% I WILL SAY THOUGH FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE TESTING
POSITIVE AT THE RATE LAURA
THOSE TWENTY YEAR OLD THIRTY
BUYING LARGE THEY'RE PRESENTING
A MILDER THE MASS AND- A GOOD
THING. IT'S GOOD THING IN TERMS
OF THE HEALTH NOT MAKE IT
HARDER TO CAN THAT SPREAD
BICKER AS IF THEY IS SO ONE I
DON'T EVEN THINK YOU WORKING
UNTIL YOU WERE RALLY ILL ITSELF
YOU GET A ALL YOU CAN I PLAYED
AND I COULD OPERATE MOST. HABIT
I'M NOT EXHIBIT SAME FOR VERY
VERY MINOR. UP WITH IT WANT TO
GO SEE. AND THAT'S JUST NOT
FACTUALLY TRUE WE KNOW WHERE
THE RISK IS WE KNOW WHO THE
COMORBIDITIES THAT ARE IMPACTED
WE GOT DATE ON THIS NOW. WE
KNOW WHO THE FOLKS ARE WHO ARE
MORE VULNERABLE WHO NEED TO BE
PROTECTED SO IT'S A VERY
SERIOUS THING- AND I DON'T
THINK HE WAS TRYING TO MINIMIZE
IT BUT I MEAN CLEARLY WE'VE
REVIEWED A SERIES FROM THE
BEGINNING IN JANUARY. WHEN WE
WERE MONITORING IT- BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WHEN YOU HEAR NEWS
ABOUT CASES I JUST THINK THAT
SHOULD BE PUT IN THE PROPER
CONTEXT AND PERSPECTIVE. THAT
THE NUMBER ONE H. FOR CASES IN
FLORIDA IS TWENTY ONE. AND IF
YOU'RE TWENTY ONE AND YOU DON'T
HAVE SIGNIFICANT COMORBIDITIES.
YOUR YOUR FIDELITY RATE IS
PRETTY MUCH ZERO- WITH THAT AND
SO THAT'S THAT THAT'S GOOD TO
ME THAT'S COMFORTING TO KNOW.
WHEN YOU SEE THE CASES THAT
IT'S AFFECTING FOLKS WHO ARE
LESS LIKELY TO SEE CLINICAL
CONSEQUENCES. THAN SOME FOLKS
AT AND I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE
EVEN BEFORE WE START TO SEE
MORE CASES. YOU'RE FROM A
CLINICAL PERSPECTIVE I THOUSAND
CASES UNDER THE AGE OF THIRTY
IT'S GONNA BE LESS SIGNIFICANT.
THAN FIFTY CASES IN A LONG TERM
CARE FACILITY THAT'S JUST THE
WAY THIS VIRUS AT WORK IT'S
VERY. HM ON THE MORBIDITIES.
ONE YOU THE SIX HUNDRED THE
PEOPLE. FIRED A LOT OF PEOPLE
DIDN'T REALLY KNOW THAT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW OF MORE HERE'S WORK I
DON'T THINK THAT IF THEY DID
NOT ON. WANT TO GO TO THE END
OF THE YEAR NOT THAT WELL WHAT
I WANT TO SEE I THINK IN THEIR
DISCUSSING IT IN THE CAR AND
NEXT IF THEY DO AND ROUND IS A.
IS PROVIDING PEOPLE IF THEY DO
GO BACK TO WORK AND TAKE THEIR
JOB. MAYBE A FINANCE PREEMIE TO
DO THAT BECAUSE- NOW. THERE IS
A DISINCENTIVE DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOUR WAGES. IF YOU HAD
SOME TYPE OF PREMIUM. THEN IF
THERE'S MORE OF AN INCENTIVE TO
WANT TO GO BACK AND SO- SO I
THINK THAT THEY SHOULD
STRUCTURE IT DIFFERENTLY BUT I
BUT I WOULD SUPPORT THEM DOING
SOMETHING. TO BE ABLE TO- GET
TO GET PEOPLE TO KEEP THEM ON
THEIR FEET GET A BACK IN THE
WORKFORCE. AND DO I MEAN WE'VE
SEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE GET BACK
IN THEIR JOBS- AFTER THE KIND
OF THE MARCH APRIL- I SHUT
DOWN. THE PROBLEM IS THAT I SEE
IS YOU KNOW SOME OF THOSE JOB
YOU'VE GOT TO GET A COMEBACK.
BUT THE QUESTION IS. GOING TO
BE 50% 90% I MEAN IF IT'S FIFTY
PERCENT. YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME PROBLEMS IF IT'S
NINETY PERCENT. YOU KNOW WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO KIND OF DEAL
WITH THAT- SO HERE IN FLORIDA
YOU KNOW WE OBVIOUSLY I HAVEN'T
THE JOB NUMBER. YET FOR OUR
STATE IN PARTICULAR BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT THE NATIONAL NUMBERS
YOU KNOW WE'RE OBVIOUSLY
ANTICIPATING. A POSITIVE BAPAT
INCREASE- LORD. REFLECT JUNE.
AT. TWENTY AT AT. WHAT I THANK
GOD THE HERE AT BROTHER HARD
WORK I WANT TO THANK DR FOR
PARTNER WITH THE STATE ON IN OF
VERY NEAT YOU KNOW WE DID A-
SURVEILLANCE PROJECT THAT THE
VILLAGES I THINK I WAS PROBABLY
MARCH OR APRIL PRETTY EARLY ON
AND WE WANTED TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE
ARE A SYMPTOMATIC BECAUSE AT
THAT TIME YOU WOULD EVEN GET A
TEST UNLESS YOU ADD SYMPTOMS-
WHICH A LOT OF PEOPLE TESTING
POSITIVE NOW PROBABLY WOULD NOT
HAVE MET THE CRITERIA BUT AT
THAT TIME. IN H. TOWN IN THERE
WAS A SYMPTOMATIC COMPONENT
WHEN WE SAID OKAY YOU KNOW THAT
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE WE HAVE
LIMITED RESOURCES BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE SYMPTOMATIC SCENE SO
THEY I THINK WOULD YOU TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED OR. FOURTEEN
HUNDRED FOUR THOUSAND EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND EIGHT SYMPTOMATIC
SENIORS AND. NOT A SINGLE
INFECTION RIGHT. LESS THAN ONE
PER MEAN YOU KNOW I THINK THE
FOR. ROUND THEY THEY GET ZERO
THAN THE MORE THEY GOT A FEW
BUT I MEAN VERY VERY LOW
PREVALENCE NOW PART OF THAT IS
THEY WERE DOING A GOOD JOB HERE
TO BILL WHICH IS. PART OF IT I
THINK AS WE NOW KNOW IS YOU
KNOW YOU DIDN'T SEE THIS REALLY
COME THROUGH FLORIDA. OUTSIDE
OF SOUTH FLORIDA UNTIL WE GOT
INTO JUNE SO I BET YOU IF WE
DID THAT PROBABLY BE HIGHER NOW
HOPEFULLY STILL PRETTY LOW
BECAUSE THEY'VE DONE A REALLY
GOOD JOB HERE- BUT THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING THAT. AND THEN- YOU
HAVE HEALTH THEY STARTED DOING
THE TESTING IN LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS PUBLIC HOUSING.
AND THAT REALLY PROVIDED THE
INSPIRATION FOR US TO DO ALL OF
OUR WALK UP SITES. SO WE HAVE
ALL THESE WALK UP SO LATE IN
UNDER SERVED- LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE NOW. PEOPLE
COULD GO. AT THE TOP I'M
GETTING A LOT OF PEOPLE TO TECH
IN MAY. AND I THE AT THE GOP
NOW WE GO A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
THREE SITES JUST THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE THERE FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE. I DID ABLE TO DO THAT AND-
WHAT THEY DO. IN JACK'S. REALLY
DI THAT SAY OKAY. ONE THING
HAVE A BIG DRAW THROUGH. IT'S
ONE THING FOR THE HOSPITALS ARE
DOCTORS. TO DO IT BUT WE REALLY
NEED TO BRING TESTING TO THE
PEOPLE AND GET IT IN AREAS
WHICH ARE VERY. CONVENIENT FOR
FOLKS AND QUITE FRANKLY. ONE AT
THAT THIS TO A VEHICLE FINDS.
SO WE WANT DO THAT. THE STAFF
ALSO. FOR TWO WORKING WITH YOU
ONE. I WOULD LIKE TO. I IS.
YOUR I THINK WE NEED STAY. WHY
SCIENTIFIC. VALLEY STAY. WHY
SERRA PREV. THAT STUDY SO IF
YOU GUYS ARE IN. IN WITH THE-
WE HAVE ONE UNIVERSITY MIAMI
MIAMI DADE. WE HAVE THIS DATED
ONE FROM- THE CDC NOW FOR
SOUTHERN FLORIDA. BUT THAT IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT TO
KNOW. THE SERO PREVALENCE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. BECAUSE
THE HIGHER THE SERRA
PREVALENCE. THE LESS THE
ABILITY THE VIRUS IS GONNA HAVE
TO SPREAD. I SAW SOME OF THESE
AREAS YOU KNOW THAT IF THEY
FIFTEEN TWENTY PERCENT. YOU
KNOW THE VIRUS DOESN'T DOESN'T
EXPAND AS MUCH. I SAID YOU HAVE
A VERY LOW CEREBRI ONES. AND
IT'S GOT MORE WORK POTENTIAL
TARGETS ARE TO REACH. SO I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. NOT
ONLY TO GET THROUGH THIS
PERIOD. BUT NOT KNOWING WHAT
MAY HAPPEN YOU KNOW IN THE
FALL. TO GET INTO. THE SEASON.
I TO HAVE. THAT SCORES OF
INFORMATION. I THINK IT'S GONNA
BE VERY. IMPORTANT WE WANT TO
WORK. AT THAT TIME ALL RIGHT
EVERYBODY.